ich möchte dass wir im gespräch bleiben
miteinander die linken die rechten die
schlauen die dummen die oberen und die
unteren und es ist denn heute der beginn
der impfwoche da setzte es bei mir ja
schon aus ich bin also der berühmte
zweimal geimpft ältere mensch der nicht
begreifen kann das 60 millionen sich
diesen schluss geben lassen aber 20 und
ich habe heute in einer umfrage gesehen
die sind zwischen 18 und 59 jährige da
fehlen 20 die größte prozentsatz derer
die feen ist in diesem
entscheidungsreifen alter sag ich mal
und ich kann es nicht verstehen dass
menschen aus diffusen gründen denn
offensichtlich es gibt eine kleine
gruppe von menschen die gesundheitlich
da nicht wenn wir die aufnehmen kommen
wir trotzdem über 80 prozent und 80
prozent würden und sozusagen über die
zielgerade bringen aber die 20 millionen
die fehlen ich begreife die nicht und
ich sage die müssten dann aber eine
konsequenz spüren sei es dass die tests
was kosten sei es dass sie gewisse dinge
dass sie die teilhabe an gewissen dingen
verlieren aber ich weiß gar nicht ob das
noch auf dem boden des grundgesetzes ist
ich möchte keinen zwang ausüben aber ich
verstehe die mentalität von menschen
nicht die etwas erreichen könnten für
das gesamte für die gesamte nation ist
es nicht tun kann man mir das erklären
also ich habe dazu zwei punkte die
eigentlich gar nichts miteinander zu tun
haben einmal zu dieser frage wie kriegt
man mehr menschen dazu zu dem was du
sagst es glaube ich die einfachste
antwort geld 50 euro für jeden sage ich
der sich impfen lässt meinetwegen auch
im nachhinein bei allem was wir für
krone ausgegeben ich glaube das thema
erledigt zu der frage warum sind da
immer noch viele so widerspenstig ich
habe darauf auch keine wirklich
flächendeckend erklärung aber ich frage
mich manchmal und ich bin fast schon
vorsichtig darin dass auszudrücken wir
sind ja unter anderem weil du auch diese
altersgruppe erwähnt hast das land von
kontakten eine einzige tablette und man
schläft sanft in der schwangerschaft das
war ein versprechen der medizin um es
ausdrücklich zu sagen ich persönlich
glaube an nichts dergleichen bei
impfstoffen ich bin auch doppelt geimpft
ich glaube nicht an nehme ich liebe
impfstoff ich liebe impfstoff erfinder
aber müssen wir die doch vielleicht
einmal berücksichtigen das ist das dass
wir eben in einem land leben vielleicht
euro gerissen alter egal was ich
erreicht habe also ich bin total gegen
die impfpflicht ich bin total gegen
zwang und allein die vorstellung dass
wir jetzt die tests von den leuten
bezahlen lassen nur um sie zu gängeln
damit sie sich impfen lassen ist doch
komplett konträr denn lockdown und die
schließung von der wirtschaft in vielen
teilen restaurants events uns bei der
hat uns milliarden gekostet und jetzt
wollen wir die test ungarn zu sehen du
bist du angesteckt also die anderen zu
kontaktieren die wollen wir jetzt
kostenpflichtig machen damit weniger
menschen die tests machen damit wir
wieder unsicherer leben nur um die
menschen zugänge
so kommen uns kompliziert machen nein
sagen nicht komplett
öffentlich ich bin ich bin auch gegen
eine impfpflicht und trotzdem finde ich
es in ordnung wir haben schon so viele
millionen milliarden ausgegeben für
diese tests wenn man dann irgendwann
sagt hey du willst sich nicht impfen
lassen in ordnung aber da musst du halt
für deinen test bezahlen
ich habe mal eine frage wir sind ja im
moment der sterblichkeit corona gibt es
viele diskussionen darüber wie tödlich
ist corinna bei wem ist in corona
wirklich töten es gibt unter es gibt
unterschiedliche zeit mal zum thema
impfpflicht weil dieser satz ich bin
gegen eine impfpflicht erfasste ein
mantra geworden ist was man erst mal
sagen muss damit man nicht von der
anderen seite richtig schöner als auf
die möglichen
ab wie viel prozent steigen ab wie viel
prozent sterblichkeit bei der nächsten
pandemie sind wir eigentlich für
impfpflicht 3 prozent 10 prozent jeder
zweite ist zuviel firma wann wann wann
sagen wir denn weil wir immer sagen nein
ich bin gegen ihre pflicht ab wie viel
prozent sterblichkeit auch bei 50 über
50 70 jährige ab wie viel prozent würden
wir dann sagen das gerechtfertigt weil
es waren ja schon sehr viele tote jetzt
ich bin niemals von denen vielleicht
lernen ja ich schließe mich da
tatsächlich lena an weil ich auch ich
glaube das ist ein freiheitlich
entscheidungen geben muss von menschen
die sich nicht impfen lassen wollen mit
der konsequenz dass wir möglicherweise
die vierte welle bekommen der nicht
geimpften das ist so aber wer sich dafür
entscheidet
der darf starte ich dazu nicht gezwungen
wird muss aber alle konsequenzen tragen
und dann meinetwegen auch die tests
zahlen aber unbedarften dann auch nur
noch als getestet da rein bin auch
dagegen dass man nur noch kämpfte und
eben genesen irgendwo rein lässt muss
nicht frei getestet auch die möglichkeit
haben aber
das wird dann dazu führen dass wir
weitaus mehr fälle haben werden was
nicht passieren darf dass wir dann in
einen neuen job bekommen
das muss klar sein und das ist ja auch
von allen ausgeschlossen mir ist halt
irgendwie wichtig dass wir irgendwann
auch wieder zum normalen leben
zurückkehren können dass wir wieder
vielleicht auch mal ohne maske irgendwo
hingehen können ganz irgendwann moment
ist es am bahnhof ist nicht das wäre
doppelt games seinen tragen müssen naja
ich wünsche mir auf jeden fall dass wir
irgendwann wieder in das normale leben
zurück kommen und ich sehe das halt nur
wenn wir möglichst viele menschen dazu
motivieren sich eben jene politiken
pandemie also ehrlich gesagt wenn ich
irgendwie noch irgendwo am flughafen
laufe kein mensch ist um mich rum und
dann wieder jemand kommt und sagt ziehen
sie die maske auf ich meine impfausweis
sage und wieder gegängelt wäre das ist
für mich eine politik pandemie da wird
jetzt auch nicht nur höhere impfquote
dann daran wahrscheinlich was ändern da
muss jetzt sagen hat nena aus meiner
sicht durchaus den punkt ich verstehe
nicht warum ich als geimpfter mich in
diversen umfeldern noch an dieser ich
verstehe es intellektuell nicht ich
halte das für irrational
ich halte es für absolut irrational dass
man sagt wir entwickeln folgt der
wissenschaft wir entwickeln einen
impfstoff schützt davor auf
herausragende weise wir können alle nur
dankbar sein aber ich muss mich trotzdem
weiter mit einer maske dorf beschützen
er mir ist es unter und ich habe auch
das gefühl die politik lebt inzwischen
diese regeln und ich habe das gefühl
dass der wahlkampf und die pandemie
zusammengefallen sind das hält uns
gerade darin gefangen niemand traut sich
uns daraus zu befreien weil er im
wahlkampf bei dem thema keinen fehler
machen ich liebe diese massen pflicht
wirklich auch gar nicht ich verfiel zug
und ganz ehrlich immer nach vier stunden
da mit einer maske saß irgendwann denkt
man auch mal wird irgendwie ein bisschen
spricht aber zum schluss ist es halt so
wir haben so viele menschen die
mittlerweile geändert werden die alle zu
kontrollieren das würde ewigkeiten
dauern werden diskutieren ja überhaupt
schon ab 3g überhaupt nachprüfbar wäre
in einem zug geht aus ihr sei auch nicht
nötig aber dann sagen ich würde in allen
filmen gehört hatten müssen alle
maßnahmen fallen weil wenn alles im
angebot hatten dann hätten sie sie ja
schützen können und wenn sie sich dann
anstecken einem sorry aber wieder
umgedacht und dadurch mehr
nachvollziehbar im zug wenn er meine
fahrkarte kontrolliert dann kann er doch
genauso kontrollieren wo ist mein ich
gesagt ja auch ein restaurant geht doch
genauso das große problem an dem ganzen
thema geimpft oder ungeimpft ist doch am
ende gar nicht so sehr ob sich jetzt
eine ungeimpfte mit corona ansteckt für
unsere gesellschaft das große problem
ist doch dass wir unsere gesellschaft in
zwei lager gespalten haben dass wir das
hätten wir uns niemals vorstellen können
dass sich menschen auf einmal fragen
darf ich dein gelben auswahl sehen der
hat sicher sein aus falls nicht aber
selbst getestet darf der nicht in das
lokal oder der darf nicht mehr zum
fußball das ist doch eigentlich die
eskalation rutschig das gilt für die ich
genauso
ja aber das muss ich ehrlich sagen dass
es mal das ist mal diese form von
unerbittlichen lagern gibt die sich da
gegenüber stehen und einander darüber
belehren wollen wie sie zu lernen haben
wovor sie angst haben dürfen wofür nicht
leben wir nicht in einer zeit wo es
immer mehr unerbittliche gegeneinander
gruppen gibt das kannte ich nicht so bin
ich nicht groß geworden aber es geht in
diese richtung es geht da schlimm sich
blöcke politisch
gesundheitspolitisch bildungspolitisch
gegenüber und beschimpfen sich geradezu
das ist schade dass das anders wird
deswegen sitzen wir alle deswegen setzen
wir uns getestete alle kämpfen getestet
ganz konnte sogar geschminkt
mein letzter fragen wer ist mit was
geimpft kippte bayern tag zweimal bei
montech thomas piontek
contact montag auf seiner anhänger und
wähler auch biontech ich auch besser
runde für die deutsche
und 150 bei der atmung und steht dann
können noch keiner mit somit zum 150 den
gerannt wir waren vorher so wir haben
uns dich verändert durch der impfstoff
wir sind alle noch klein wir sind alle
noch am leben wir hatten alle keine
dramatische nebenwirkungen sind wir sind
alle immer noch jeden abend gerne hier
um zu diskutieren
viertel nach acht der top der
schlagzeilen macht
[Musik]